[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance do you think Donald Trump
realizes that the American intelligence
community has already started to kill
and eat his presidency the leaks the
drip drip drip
the tiny revelation that cost Michael
Flynn the national security advisors job
the slightly larger revelation that was
the play-by-play of how and why his
first three choices to succeed Flynn
didn't succeed Flynn the larger
revelations that put the backbone in the
New York Times and CNN stories about the
Trump campaign talking with Russia while
still hiding the potentially disastrous
details of exactly what they said and
the far more meaningful revelation with
the far more subtle revelation that the
so-called British dossier is gaining
credibility within the intelligence
agencies because they have been able to
confirm so many little details like how
the claims of meetings and phone calls
on specific dates are turning out to be
exactly right you think Trump
understands what all these things are
they are warnings they are the cop
letting the belligerent drunk see just
the tip of the gun they are the poker
player putting down the $20 chips then
smiling at the mark then pulling back
the $20 chips and replacing them with
hundred-dollar chips they are warnings
stories based on sources usually bear no
resemblance to what you see in the
movies or on television dramas it's not
all all the President's Men with
indefatigable and annoying pests
overwhelming reluctant individuals until
the latter do the right thing I mean you
might have enough sources who are around
the center but not at the center of a
given story and with all the
circumstantial evidence they have
provided you you might once in a while
be able to persuade that key reluctant
source to confirm what you have already
proved to them that you actually know
but this is almost always true a source
does not give you a story because you
want them to give it to you a source
gives you a story because they want to
give it to you and there are sources a
lot of sources a lot of very well-placed
very well informed sources who want
to tell the world about Donald Trump the
details they are doling out have a dual
purpose they get these stories out to
confirm the correct perception that this
administration is like a giant fire hose
that the firefighters have lost control
of but more importantly they are there
to get the message to Trump and those
around him that there is an iceberg and
it will be revealed one square foot at a
time so stop screwing around maybe he's
not smart enough to get it maybe he's
not sane enough to get it maybe he's not
experienced enough to get it that
individuals sitting on details potent
enough to pick off his national security
adviser hours after Kellyanne con job
said he had Trump's full confidence
there also clearly sitting on a horde of
far more embarrassing far more
destructive far more lurid details about
Trump so why aren't those lurid details
known already well this part is entirely
speculative of course but the way we
'king in the intelligence community or
as they sometimes phrase it story
placement was explained to me it is
supposed to be done with the minimum
expenditure of assets in other words to
go back to that analogy of the poker
player pulling back the $20 chips and
replacing them with hundred-dollar chips
you want to use as little of your stash
as possible each chip each story you
confirm or promulgate involves something
you then can no longer use for its
original purpose the essence of
intelligence is secrecy reveal a secret
to a reporter and you may reveal within
the worldwide intelligence community a
thousand details of how you learned that
secret why spend the hundred dollar
chips when you might get the job done
with the 20s and it's clear that the
Oliver Stone version of the intelligence
community is at best an exaggeration
Trump derided the I see as it calls
itself during the campaign insulted the
IC after the election impugn the IC
during the transition and yet for the
most part the spies kept quiet whatever
they thought of Trump with their great
restraint and to their great credit they
clearly wanted to grin and bear through
a trump administration and then it
became clear he wasn't going to stop but
what pushed
over the edge again just a guess but I
suspect that speech at CIA headquarters
with Trump's disingenuous shallow
fawning over them while he bought his
own employees along to applaud him that
was certainly the end of the beginning
as far as the intelligence community's
forbearance and then came his noted
disinterest in their products their
briefings and finally came the night he
took in the details of the North Korean
missile test while the gawking patrons
at night mera Lago the judged smells and
the doctor beeper and the hammer camps
and the mrs. crane of Trump's real-life
enactment of the movie Caddyshack while
they all took cell phone pictures and
the next thing you knew the Wall Street
Journal had a story about how US
intelligence agencies are not telling
Trump everything for fear it quote could
be leaked or compromised and then CBS
News had a story about Trump yelling
about that story at his CIA director and
then Huffington Post had a story about
how the president only wants bullet
points in his Intel briefings and how he
really likes maps a Newsweek had a story
about one Western European ally
intercepting the Flyn phone calls with
supposedly the Russian ambassador and
Politico had a story about a senior
National Security Council official
criticizing Trump and his team and
getting fired for it and the New York
Times just happened to hear about a
military conference where the general in
charge of US Special Operations Command
suddenly blurts out our government
continues to be an unbelievable turmoil
and later clarifies through a reporter
quote as a commander I'm concerned our
government be as stable as possible
remarks that seemed about as subtle as
saying golly
as servicemembers who love and honor the
Constitution we would hate to have to do
a military takeover of the government
but [ __ ] McGee over here is a whack
job and none of it registers with Trump
on he goes threatening the leakers the
leakers he compared once to Nazi Germany
the leakers who have all the chips the
twenties the hundreds for all we know
the millions on he goes tweets this a
week ago information is being illegally
given to them failing New York Times in
Washington Post by the intelligence
community NSA an FBI just like Russia
the real scandal here is that classified
information is illegally given out by
intelligence like candy very unamerican
on American just like Russia Nazi
Germany whereupon somebody asks John
Schindler a former NSA guy who left his
job at the Naval War College under
embarrassing circumstances but whose
tweets about Trump and the intelligence
community have been remarkably prescient
quote what do you think is going on
inside that sack right now national
security after Trump's intelligence
tweet this morning and schindler tweets
back now we gonna clear IC intelligence
community war going to new levels just
got an e/m from senior IC friend
it began quote he will die in jail do
you think Donald Trump realizes that the
American intelligence community has
already started to kill and eat his
presidency resist peace